[Music]
on this Thursday night a tornado Roars
through an Ottawa suburb everything
started to shake the damage and the
frightening moments for people
the heat is on they were no shoes they
are dizzy the scorching weather roasting
southern Europe
attended a deal in the BC Port strike
the cautious optimism so we're not out
of the lid yet
and in Hollywood lights camera job
action why actors are joining writers on
the picket line
and Hoot this person seems to have an ax
to grind why this basketball net is
hoarding controversy
global national with Donna Friesen
[Music]
it happened with no warning in the
middle of the day a tornado touched down
in an Ottawa suburb today damaging roofs
shattering windows and sending debris
flying part of a dangerous storm system
that ripped through parts of eastern
Ontario and into Southern Quebec the
entire island of Montreal was under a
tornado warning at one point that's
since been lifted but Environment Canada
confirms a tornado did touch down near
Mirabelle airport Northwest of Montreal
it was in Barrhaven Ontario a suburb
about 40 minutes south of Parliament
Hill that it appears the most
significant damage occurred from today's
storm at least 125 homes there were
damaged Global's David Baxter is there
assessing the damage and talking to
Witnesses David
Donna this is just some of the damage of
a tornado that ripped through the
southern Ottawa suburb of Barrhaven
earlier this afternoon now behind me you
can see the large styrofoam blocks from
a construction site they blew across a
field and landed in front of these Town
Homes causing quite a bit of damage and
if we look up you could see the damaged
roof of these Town Homes as well the
damaged rooms a pretty common sight in
the area now this is a very fast and
furious storm that came in with little
to no warning for the residents in the
area we saw a huge cloud and I wasn't
sure what it was and then I live
streamed to my friend and we started
seeing the floating debris and the
swirls so I started running downstairs
and by the time I was downstairs and it
stopped and I looked out
I lost four shingles off my roof in a
fence so I'm very lucky compared to some
other people around here
the storm passed almost as quickly as it
formed but the trail of damage Left
Behind is evidence of its intensity
everything started to shake it was a
rude awakening from Muhammad Omar he was
taking a lunch hour nap when the storm
hit the windshield of his car is broken
but he's thankful to damage in the area
is only superficial as long as
everyone's okay no one's hurt that's the
most important part between the damaged
roofs a smashed window and even a piece
of wood driven through a fence the
severity of this storm is obvious but
for residents the lead-up was not many
in the area saying they did not receive
the tornado warning on their phones
until the storm was already in progress
now the Ottawa paramedic service says
they did have to take one person to the
hospital after they were struck by a
flying piece of debris but thankfully
that person did not suffer any
life-threatening injuries and is in
stable condition Donna okay David Baxter
and barhaven a suburb of Ottawa thanks
there is more dangerous weather to tell
you about tonight in Europe and the
southwestern U.S more than 110 million
people from Arizona Arizona to Florida
are under some sort of heat warning
tonight Phoenix has hit 43 degrees
Celsius or higher for the last 13 days
in a row at least 12 people have died
from heat in Arizona this year 55 more
possible heat deaths are under
investigation temperatures could reach
46 to 49 degrees Celsius in some areas
this weekend and and people in southern
Europe are also sweltering under
record-breaking heat in Italy red alerts
have been issued from multiple cities
because of a heat wave that's been
dubbed Cerberus the three-headed dog in
Greek mythology that guards the Gates of
Hell alerts are in place in Spain Italy
and Greece where temperatures are
expected to hit 48 degrees Celsius in
some areas this week this heat map shows
the ground temperature in Spain reaching
a scorching 60 degrees Celsius on
Tuesday the hottest areas turned from
red to Black in Croatia people are
relying on an old method to cool off
covering themselves in mud our Europe
bureau chief Crystal commencing on the
effects of this unbearable Heat
from the Acropolis stunning views of
Athens can be admired but many visitors
might have a hard time seeing with salty
beads of sweat dripping into their eyes
oppressive temperatures brought out the
Red Cross as those waiting hours in
massive lines begin suffering the
effects of heat stroke they were no
shoes they are dizzy they don't feel
well they want somewhere to sit the
ancient sites of Greece offer visitors
many things but shade and air
conditioning are not on the list
the blistering sun is also scorching for
those lining up to get into Vatican
Museums Rome saw temperatures reach 34
degrees Celsius today it's still okay
because we're a little bit out of the
Sun but we were yesterday at the
Colosseum and then it was like 38
degrees the extreme condition should no
longer be shocking says this climate
scientist certainly we should
immediately stop pumping greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere because that
is the that's going to cause even more
problems in the future but we must
realize we're locked into some of these
changes now and we will continue to see
records broken red alerts have been
issued for at least 10 Italian cities
including Rome by the Ministry of Health
for the next two days researchers for
European health institutes estimated
more than 61 thousand people from across
35 European countries died last year of
heat-related causes it was the hottest
summer on record so far it it's really
hard I've got asthma so this heat is
terrible yeah for it we were in Rome and
I had to actually have a paramedics call
because the heat was so bad and getting
cool is a challenge air conditioning is
rare in most European homes
Crystal gomancing Global News London
after nearly two weeks a tentative deal
has been reached in the strike at the BC
port in Vancouver the federal labor
Minister has now left Vancouver after
the two sides agreed on a contract
drafted by a federal mediator the labor
disruption cost the Canadian economy an
estimated 500 million dollars a day and
as nithu garcha reports the effects will
linger for a long time
cargo operations at British Columbia
ports are set to be restored quickly as
the workers strike has come to an end on
its 13th day
a statement from the employer announced
a tentative four-year deal recognizing
the skills and efforts of BC's
Waterfront Workforce no details have
been made public with the agreement
subject to ratification by both parties
business groups are welcoming the news
but caution what's ahead fantastic news
that this has been settled but the
damage has been done there's weeks and
weeks if not months of backlog to get
through uh so we're not out of the woods
yet a joint statement from the federal
labor and transport Minister says deals
like this made between parties at the
collective bargaining table are the best
way to preserve the long-term stability
of Canada's economy but we do not want
to be back here again this does set a
precedent for actually bargaining at the
table but some labor experts accuse
business groups of not acting in good
faith given how quickly they called for
Back To Work legislation when any
Province any territory wants to raise
the minimum wage they all cry out and
say no no we can't afford it and the
government shouldn't and shouldn't
interfere in the economy and the minute
workers take some power back they're
like oh government please help us the
union and the employer were given 24
hours to review recommendations ordered
by labor Minister Sheamus O'Regan before
deciding on the deal some 7400 BC port
workers walked off the job on July 1st
the work stoppage affecting about 30
ports in BC including Canada's largest
the port of Vancouver disrupted billions
in trade and demanding attention at this
week's premier's meetings workers need
to be treated fairly
and the issue at the Port cannot drag on
because it has a profoundly damaging
impact across the country on workers
that are also trying to feed their
families right now key issues for the
union were wages and cost of living
Contracting outside work and automation
labor P seems to have been achieved as
efforts now aim to restore the
reputation of Canada's largest Gateway
nitugarja Global News Vancouver
first it was the screenwriters now
Hollywood actors are going on strike it
means scripted TV and movie production
will cease immediately in what is the
first dual work stoppage by both actors
and writers in 63 years today the head
of the actors Union said the Studio's
responses to the actors concerns have
been insulting and disrespectful
we are the victims here we are being
victimized by a very greedy entity
I am shocked by the way the people that
we have been in business with are
treating us I cannot believe it quite
frankly
how far apart we are on so many things
actors say they will be on the picket
line tomorrow Jackson prosco on what
they're demanding and how the strike
will impact what you watch
this Blockbuster labor dispute will shut
down production for both big screen and
small Hollywood will go dark actors are
looking for compensation that keeps up
with inflation they're looking for a
sustainable career and they are looking
to not be replaced by AI those are the
key issues at play here the effects will
be immediate film and scripted series
will cease production actors won't
promote movies that are already finished
in London the stars of Oppenheimer
walked out of the film's premiere we had
to protect the people who were kind of
on the margins and there are a lot of
people who residual payments are what
carry them across that threshold
and if the dispute drags on the red
carpet will sit empty at events like the
Toronto International Film Festival the
entire infrastructure of Hollywood's
affected their economies that are
impacted all over the U.S and all over
the world pay is arguably the biggest
issue many actors say the Hollywood
dream is simply Out Of Reach especially
as streaming services flip the script on
residual payments the entire business
model has been changed
by streaming digital AI
this is a moment of history that is a
Moment of Truth The Alliance of motion
picture and television producers
representing major Studios says it
offered what it called historic pay and
residual increases a federal mediator
was unable to bring the two sides
together from the producer's perspective
the demands of the actors are
unrealistic at a time when the when the
business truly is in a state of Crisis
what do we want a crisis made worse by
another labor dispute screenwriters
walked off the job more than 70 days ago
over the exact same issues in their
absence TV networks had already prepared
a fall schedule full of unscripted
reality shows in some ways this strike
couldn't be timed worse for the artist
and couldn't be timed better for the
studios and streamers because they were
already in a severe cost cutting mode
leaving audiences at a loss for new
content at a time when there are more
ways to watch than ever
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
Toronto police have arrested and charged
a man with second-degree murder related
to a shooting last week that killed an
innocent bystander 44-year-old Carolina
hubner makarat was hit by a stray bullet
last Friday while walking in Toronto's
Leslieville neighborhood police alleged
32-year-old Damian Hudson was one of
three men involved in an altercation
that led to an exchange of gunfire
Hudson was out on bail at the time and
had been convicted of a number of
offenses including violent assault
police are still trying to identify the
two other men involved
in Winnipeg tensions are flaring after
the provincial government decided not to
support the search of a landfill site
for the remains of indigenous women who
were believed to have been dumped there
last year there have been days of
protests as a group of demonstrators
blocked the entrance to the landfill
site as Melissa ridgeen reports a judge
is now deciding whether to Grant an
injunction to remove that blockade
this is one of several confrontations
making rounds on social media take care
of
then why are they dead bursts against a
blockade set up by those demanding a
search of landfills for the bodies of
missing or murdered indigenous women
just confrontation Days Later ended up
on the man's doorstep
police have charged a 19 year old with
Mischief for a rock thrown through a
window no charges have been laid for the
red spray-painted handprints I'd rather
the money be spent on living women who
could be protected instead of women who
are already dead
we deserve a peaceful burial though too
the Manitoba government announced last
week it won't support that spurring this
unrest
saying a search would cost too many
millions take many months or years and
would put Searchers at risk digging
through thousands of tons of toxic
densely compacted waste here at the
Prairie green landfill where police
believe Morgan Harris and Mercedes
Myron's remains are this has been dealt
with in a very heartless way
we
an online petition with more than 35 000
signatures agrees they need to go and
get them you know I'm not going to have
my nieces go sit at a landfill to visit
their mom for the rest of Eternity it
remains to be seen if Ottawa will commit
to foot that bill a judge hasn't yet
ruled on the city's request for an
injunction to remove the blockade
Melissa Ridge in Global News Winnipeg
the scoop on an artificial sweetener
coming up the World Health Organization
weighs in on the safety of aspartame
the first over-the-counter birth control
pill has been approved in the U.S Paving
the way for millions of women to buy
contraceptives without a prescription
drug maker perigo will start selling its
once a day pill early next year the
change is expected to broaden access for
young women and those from low-income
and minority backgrounds who often face
extra hurdles getting a prescription
hormone-based pills have long been the
most common form of birth control in the
United States there is some news from
the World Health Organization about a
common artificial sweetener the who has
declared aspartame to be a possible
carcinogen to humans that sounds
worrying because it's been approved for
use in drinks and food for decades and
critics say this new warning will spark
needless alarm and mislead consumers
Catherine Ward puts the whole thing into
perspective
when aspartame was invented in the 1960s
the food additive was one way to curb
the amount of sugar in processed food
the World Health Organization has now
labeled aspartame as possibly
carcinogenic to humans under the 2B
classification that might sound alarming
but experts even the ones with the
research group who presented the
findings say there is no need to panic
it means it is acceptable to consume a
certain amount of aspartame without
having appreciable health effects in our
view this is really more a call to the
research Community to try to better
clarify and understand the carcinogenic
Hazard that may or may not be posed by
aspartame consumption toxicologists say
context is critical that same category
of potential risk also includes things
like aloe vera
electromagnetic fields and Wi-Fi and so
other things that that we don't really
worry about and I think one last way to
kind of put this in perspective is
something that we know as a carcinogen
is alcohol
you would have to drink a lot of diet
soda to get close to unhealthy levels of
aspartame consumption the who says you
can have up to 40 milligrams of
aspartame per kilogram of body weight
per day for an average 70 kilogram
person and sodas containing about 200
milligrams of aspartame that means up to
14 cans of diet soda
Dr Christopher labos is concerned this
key message will get lost people are
going to misinterpret this to mean
artificial sweeteners are dangerous we
have 30 40 Years of data of people
consuming these products and not really
seeing any health effects if you're
consuming diet drinks as a healthier
choice doctors say there is a better
simpler option the best way to be
healthy is to switch from regular soda
to water so when you're trying to make
that choice between you know sugar and
artificial sweeteners pick neither
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
Aerospace assault ahead and overnight
Russian drone attack on Ukraine's
capital
an investigation into the sinking of a
boat carrying hundreds of people off the
coast of Greece last month is casting
doubt on the official version of events
from the Greek Coast Guard through new
video court documents and interviews BBC
News is reporting that some migrants who
survived the sinking were pressured and
intimidated by Greek authorities after
some suggested the Coast Guard may have
played a part in in the sinking when a
rope was used to try to tow the vessel
survivors also allege they were pressed
to identify nine Egyptians on board as
traffickers those people were later
arrested Greek authorities have not
commented on the BBC report officially
at least 82 people are known to have
died the U.N estimates as many as 500
more were on board and never found
the Ukrainian Capital has come under
Russian attack for a third straight
night Ukraine says its air defenses shot
down 20 drones targeting Kiev at least
one person was killed by Falling debris
others suffered smoke inhalation from
fires sparked in apartment buildings a
military spokesperson claims Ukraine has
received cluster Munitions from the U.S
now to help bolster its offensive but
has yet to use them
and one of Keith's biggest landmarks the
motherland Monument is getting a new
steel shield with the Ukrainian Trident
it replaces the Soviet coat of arms made
in 1981. the sculptor says the Trident
which represents state power is one of
the most important symbols of Ukraine's
identity the change should be complete
by the end of August
out of bounds next basketball and bylaws
tip off in an Ottawa neighborhood
[Music]
CEO demonstrating how strong his
company's cardboard beds are they're the
official athlete beds for the Paris 2024
Olympic Games and there's another twist
each athlete will be scanned and
photographed when they go into the
athletes Village and then an AI program
will determine the best possible
mattress based on their height weight
and Sport there's a saying that good
fences make good neighbors but everyone
who lives in a city knows the boundaries
between neighbors can get blurred
sometimes one mother in an Ottawa
neighborhood has discovered that a
neighbor has complained to the city
almost a dozen times that the kids
basketball hoop is too close to the road
and as turia Israel explains the family
is jumping through hoops just so they
can play
this game of pickup basketball has an
invisible opponent an anonymous neighbor
who seems bent on getting the bouncing
to stop
this person seems to have an ax to grind
it is persistent how persistent for more
than a year the city of Ottawa has
received complaint after complaint about
the net on Rosland pasiga's driveway
dear neighbor she wrote an open letter
to her mystery neighbor pleading with
them to cut kids in the neighborhood
some slack someone has repeatedly
reported on hernette and others in the
area
according to the city's rule book the
games are out of bounds bylaw officers
have knocked on pasiga's door multiple
times asking her to move the net because
it is too close to the sidewalk
essentially our basketball net would
have to live
about this far back from the road
meaning her 10 year old and six-year-old
would have to drag it back every time
they finished playing oh I can barely
move it myself there have been nine
Anonymous complaints about basketball
nets in the area we asked around and
none of the neighbors who we spoke to
had a problem with the Nets so for now
the complainer's identity remains a
mystery but yeah nine complaints seems
fairly excessive I think anything that
gets kids outside playing together can
only really be a positive thing over the
years complaints have poured in about
other pastimes street hockey games even
little free libraries violate bylaws
this neighbor says it's time for people
to lighten up they're good kids I mean
would would they rather that they'd be
in a gang somewhere you know I mean
really they're safe they're in the
street nobody nobody speeds on these
streets
so who's the coffee whoever the culprit
pasiga hopes her message gets through no
I certainly don't lose faith in humanity
it would just I mean we all just want to
live in our neighborhood
um together reminding the community that
being a good neighbor also means being a
good sport teria is rate Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Lac beaur in Jasper
National Park Alberta beautiful spot
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching Nathan Garcia will be here at
the anchor desk tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]